[Música]
donald trump y joe biden se enfrentaron
en el último debate cara a cara antes de
las elecciones presidenciales del 3 de
noviembre los candidatos mostraron
diferencias irreconciliables en casi
todos los asuntos como la pandemia y la
migración el racismo y el cambio
climático el cambio de reglas para el
debate permitió un intercambio más claro
contrario al primer encuentro
españa a uno de los países más afectados
por la segunda ola de contagio seco y 19
en europa estaría por encima de los 3
millones de casos según declaraciones
del presidente del gobierno pedro
sánchez el mandatario afirmó que es
necesario limitar la movilidad y las
reuniones sociales para evitar un nuevo
confinamiento general
las partes enfrentadas en el conflicto
libio firmaron un alto el fuego
permanente gracias a la mediación de
naciones unidas la jefa de la misión de
la onu stephanie williams calificó el
acuerdo de un momento que pasará a la
historia y la unión europea celebra el
pacto mientras que turquía expresó sus
dudas al respecto
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 se redoblan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo en eeuu donde se llevó a
cabo el segundo y último debate entre
donald trump y joe biden nashville
tennessee los candidatos se mantuvieron
combativos pero sin ofenderse y bajo la
modalidad de micrófono apagado cuando no
estaban respondiendo para evitar las
interrupciones como las que se
presentaron en el primer debate uno de
los temas centrales de este cara a cara
fue nuevamente la pandemia de
coronavirus que ya el país cuenta con
más de 8 millones 400 mil casos
confirmados y más de 220 mil muertos
trump quiso hacerse valedor de su
experiencia tras haber padecido la
enfermedad afirmando que ahora es inmune
al cobit 19 y que la vacuna llegará en
cuestión de semanas mientras que joe
biden alertó sobre la gravedad de la
situación advirtiendo que el país vivirá
un invierno oscuro para ampliar esa
información vamos a hablar con antonella
martín analista política y directora del
centro ferroviario american washington
dice antonella buen día gracias
por estar con nosotros en france 24 un
gusto saludarla nuevamente parece haber
funcionado el cambio de reglas que
impedían estas interrupciones le
pregunto cuáles son las conclusiones de
este debate y cree que tendrá un impacto
real entre los votantes ya que más de 47
millones de personas han votado
buenos dias raúl qué gusto saludarte
bueno efectivamente en el día de ayer se
abarcaron varios temas como bien
mencionaba recién uno de ellos ha hecho
hincapié la en la pandemia y el manejo
de la crisis hemos vivido hemos visto
varias varias temáticas comenzando
precisamente por por la gestión y con
dos visiones bastante distintas por
parte de cada uno de los candidatos pero
también se tocaron aspectos como la
seguridad nacional la influencia de
países como rusia e irán en las
elecciones de los eeuu aspectos como en
el salario mínimo también el cambio
climático temas de emigración o aspectos
tan importantes para lo que va de esta
de esta campaña efectivamente como
también bien decías creo que en este
debate ambos candidatos mejoraron mucho
la forma eso es algo que cabe mencionar
también por el cambio de metodología
creo que se ha mejorado el trato se los
vio mucho más respetuosos a ambos
especialmente no a donald trump creo que
se pudo entender cuando hablaban cada
uno de los de los candidatos y muchas
interrupciones a diferencia de lo que
vimos en el 1er
y creo que a donald trump claramente se
lo vio mucho más cómodo que a baida en
eso también pero evidentemente lo que no
mejoraron fueron las las ideas políticas
no con ambos extremos disputándose cuál
de los dos proponía quizás más estado o
cuál de los dos repartiría más subsidios
civiles y dinero de los de los
contribuyentes
antonella sin embargo vimos johnson a la
defensiva sobre el manejo de la pandemia
y sobre temas de sus impuestos vimos
además que aprovechó en varias ocasiones
para hacer llamados a los votantes de
estados pendulares como pensilvania
donde es originario
joe biden cree que el presidente
reconoce al menos internamente está en
problemas y bailén podría perder ésta
que podría perdón perder esta elección
yo creo que efectivamente de alguna
manera eso es algo que una señal que se
pudo que se pudo observar en el debate
de ayer no creo que el manejo de la
pandemia fue dentro de todo este este
aspecto y algo que por supuesto golpe
haya golpeado bastante a los estados
unidos creo que sí efectivamente en eso
en ese análisis
estoy estoy muy de acuerdo contigo es
raúl y vuelvo a insistir creo que esta
vez se atacaron de una manera quizás
mucho más polite una manera mucho más
educada pero insisto sin dar soluciones
reales a las preguntas y muchas veces
cayendo en puros ataques personales como
dice un colega argentino respecto de
estas elecciones yo creo que el dilema
del votante norteamericano ahora es
elegir quizás entre una muerte un poco
más rápida y otra una muerte un poco más
lenta del sistema del sistema político
norteamericano en la última opción por
supuesto permite prolongar un poco más
la vida pero termina siendo un problema
al fin y al cabo pero si efectivamente
yo creo que el cambio o el viraje en el
comportamiento del presidente de donald
trump dice muchos respecto de esto no
creo que se viola la distinción sobre el
primer debate así es antonella gracias
por estar con nosotros que tenga usted
un feliz resto de día nosotros
continuamos con más información acá en
el estudio porque aunque fue poco
tratado durante el debate de otro de los
temas claves para
los comicios es la batalla por el
control de la corte suprema los
republicanos en el comité judicial de la
cámara alta aprobaron la nominación de
la fuerza conservadora y miconi para ver
y su caso pasa al pleno del senado los
demócratas han calificado el proceso de
precipitado e ilegítimo y boicotearon el
voto veamos el siguiente informe
señor presidente los votos son 12 a
favor 10
la nominación será reportada
favorablemente al senado con un voto
unánime la elegida por tom action está
un paso más cerca de será el reemplazo
de ruiz báder ginsburg en la corte
suprema en un botón boicoteado por los
demócratas los republicanos en el comité
judicial del senado aprobaron la
nominación de la jueza conservadora
amy con el barret con una audiencia de
confirmación esperada para el lunes los
martes es en momentos como este donde
puedes decir a las jóvenes conservadoras
que hay un lugar en la mesa para ellas
es un momento histórico e innovador king
story mount el presidente enfocado en su
batalla por la reelección compartió la
noticia en twitter calificándola de gran
día para estados unidos las tías de los
demócratas estaban notablemente vacías
ellos han criticado el proceso
señalándolo como demasiado precipitado y
apresurado ya que llega a menos de dos
semanas antes de las elecciones
presidenciales
[Música]
y extender la nominación de miconi
barrett es el proceso más ilegítimo que
ha presenciado el senado y su posible
confirmación tenga consecuencias
nefastas para el senado para la corte
suprema y para todo nuestro país en las
generaciones futuras
mujeres vestidas como siervas de la
popular serie de televisión basada en el
libro de margaret atwood protestaron
fuera del capitolio de eeuu están
preocupadas por el impacto que podría
tener en temas sobre el derecho al
aborto y el acceso a la salud asequible
temen además que con su nombramiento
seis de los nueve jueces de la corte
suprema sean ahora conservadores
y los defectos de un tribunal
constitucional conservador se sintieron
en polonia después de que éste fallara a
favor de considerar instrucción del
embarazo por malformación del feto como
inconstitucional los políticos
ultraconservadores celebraron la
decisión mientras que los defensores de
este derecho se manifestaron en contra
en la medida
andrew amaya nos amplía la información
la decisión del tribunal constitucional
desató críticas al interior del
parlamento polaco
no podemos estar de acuerdo con acciones
ilegales no aceptaremos el pseudo
veredicto del pseudo tribunal y tenemos
un ruego a los médicos sean valientes
juraron salvar vidas y la dignidad de
ahora en adelante la dignidad y la
seguridad de las mujeres están en sus
manos y también tenemos un ruego a las
mujeres seamos solidarias y apoyemos los
mutuamente el tribunal respondió a una
querella presentada hace tres años por
un grupo de parlamentarios del
ultraconservador y nacionalista ley
injusticia el partido que lidera una
coalición en polonia con mayoría
absoluta
en las calles miembros de grupos
denominados probidad se libraron el
fallo
[Música]
obtuvimos la confirmación de que la
matanza y selección de niños sospechosos
de defectos genéticos o enfermedades es
incompatible con la constitución polaca
el tribunal lo dictaminó por unanimidad
las reacciones en contra no se hicieron
esperar y cientos de personas que
defienden el derecho al aborto
manifestaron hasta altas horas de la
noche lo que el gobierno nos está
haciendo hoy no solo nos está quitando
nuestros derechos de las mujeres pero
también nuestros derechos humanos por
primera vez podemos decir con seguridad
que en polonia tenemos la peor ley de
aborto en europa una vez que entra en
vigor el fallo el aborto sólo estará
permitido en polonia en caso de
violación incesto o una amenaza para la
salud y la vida de la madre volviendo al
país de tradición católica como el único
de la unión europea
aparte de malta que restringe
severamente el acceso al aborto
vamos a hacer españa donde el presidente
de gobierno pedro sánchez afirmó que la
cifra real de contagios por kobe 19 que
ha habido en el país desde el inicio de
la pandemia supera los 3 millones de
personas aunque el registro oficial los
cifra en apenas poco más de un millón
sánchez se basó en los estudios de sobre
prevalencia desarrollados por las
instituciones públicas con expertos
científicos además reconoció que la
situación es grave pero aseguró que el
sistema de salud está ahora mejor
preparado y dijo que hay que evitar a
toda costa un nuevo confinamiento
nacional mientras tanto las autoridades
de madrid anunciaron la prohibición de
reuniones de personas que no viven bajo
el mismo techo entre medianoche y las
seis de la mañana los estudios de cero
prevalencia que han hecho las
instituciones públicas con expertos
científicos a la cabeza indican que el
número real de personas que han estado
infectadas en nuestro país por kobe 19
supera ya los 3 millones de compatriotas
las próximas semanas los próximos meses
ahora que entramos en el invierno serán
duro
muy duros
es cierto que contamos con la
experiencia de haber doblegado la curva
una vez y podemos lograrlo otra vez con
menores sacrificios quiero en esto ser
muy claro queremos y debemos evitar a
toda costa recurrir a un nuevo
confinamiento domiciliario como el que
vivimos durante semanas en primavera así
entonces las cosas en españa por cuenta
de esta pandemia de covite 19 cambiamos
ahora de información porque las partes
del conflicto libio acordaron un cese el
fuego permanente el anuncio fue hecho
desde la sede de naciones unidas en
ginebra suiza donde se aseguró que el
pacto es permanente y con efecto
inmediato el pacto estipula que los
combatientes extranjeros deben abandonar
el país en los próximos tres meses la
unión europea calificó el anuncio del
acuerdo entre el gobierno de acuerdo
nacional es reconocido por la comunidad
internacional y el ejército nacional
libio dirigido por califa
como muy buenas noticias
y hoy es un buen día para el pueblo
libio a las 11 15 de la mañana aquí en
las instalaciones de la onu en ginebra
las dos delegaciones libias de los
diálogos entre la comisión militar
conjunta lidia copiado de la página 55
firmaron un acuerdo para un cese al
fuego completo permanente y para toda la
nación con efecto inmediato dicho
acuerdo fue facilitado por la onu y lo
firmamos como testigos
sainz es el jugador de fútbol brasileño
edson arantes do nacimento más conocido
como pelé cumple hoy 80 años en el
siguiente informe repasamos la
trayectoria del considerado por muchos
el mejor futbolista de todos los tiempos
la discusión por quién es el mejor
jugador de todos los tiempos es
constante sin embargo no hay duda de
quién es el rey del fútbol
[Aplausos]
seleccionar antes de nacimiento nació el
23 de octubre de 1940 en tres corazones
un poblado a unos 200 kilómetros al este
de sao paulo aunque jugó en una época en
la que los negros eran lo menos
importante se le rompió todos los
récords
algunos de ellos vigentes hasta nuestros
días marcó más de 1200 goles es
actualmente el máximo goleador de la
selección brasileña tiene el mayor
número de hat tricks en la historia 92 y
es el único futbolista en ganar tres
copas del mundo suecia 58 chile 62 y
méxico 70
por estas cifras fue considerado el
mejor futbolista del siglo 20 hoy llega
a sus 80 años y los fanáticos aún lo
tienen en el olimpo del fútbol un ídolo
conservado hasta hoy una leyenda
viviente
tenemos que venerar a nuestros ídolos
mientras están con vida mientras están
aquí es un hombre que hizo mucho llevo
el nombre de brasil al mundo pese a ser
reconocido mundialmente por su
participación con la selección brasileña
pelé también tiene un palmarés
envidiable en los clubes en los que jugó
campeón con el santo de seis torneos
nacionales
libertadores y dos copas
intercontinentales tras décadas de estar
en la cima eso fin a su carrera en el
cosmos de nueva york donde jugó entre
1975 y el 77 coronándose campeón
nacional en una ocasión y haciendo que
leyendas del deporte como el boxeador
mohamed alí fueran a verle tratar de
impulsar el fútbol en eeuu
hasta que el informativo cuando llega
con nosotros
[Música]